- I'm in, like, the
biggest heel right now.
Usually I'm here.
That's amazing!
- I'm a giant.
- I look like an Oompa Loompa!
Oh my gosh, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm cheating in my heels.
How are you?
Have ya'll met before?
- This young man I think
was on the Cardinals.
- Yes I was.
- I'm from Arizona so,
of course I love it.
I know who you are.
This guy's great so,
don't just take her
word for it, take mine.
(laughing)
- Well Calais how does
it feel to receive one
of the most coveted sports awards?
That's pretty amazing.
- Uh yeah. It's been incredible.
You know I think the
biggest thing is I'm more
inspired than ever, you know?
It's gave me a lot of
motivation to want to do more.
It's pretty cool.
- And you're doing amazing things.
I love when people have
such a big spotlight.
Especially sports figures
because a lot of little
kids look up to y'all,
and the fact that you use
it for such good its
like you're super heroes.
Its really cool.
- Thank you.
I take pride in being a role model.
I really do.
- Yeah that's awesome, that's awesome.
A lot of people see it as a burden
so its awesome that you take pride in it
and you think about it positively, but
David, what is the best
award you've ever won?
What do you think?
- Kelly, I'm not really an awards guy.
(laughing)
I think its just nice
to be almost nominated.
- Almost!
(laughing)
- Now, I was up for a
Golden Globe and an Emmy.
- [Kelly] Wow!
- It went the wrong way at
the last minute when they announced it.
But it's exciting.
No, it's great.
- So Calais have you always
had such a giving spirit?
Where did it come from?
- It started with my family.
You know growing up, my parents you know,
especially my dad.
He really installed it
in us at a young age,
you have to be involved in
the community, giving back.
Even if you don't have a
lot to give back, give time.
We used to push cars out of the snow
and like, go help.
My dad used to make me
go out and help ladies
with their groceries and stuff.
- Yeah, he was raising a gentleman.
- Yeah you know, and
it really has paid off,
'cause I really am
inspired and I try to do,
I feel like the only thing you can
really control is your effort,
and I don't know if I'll make a difference
in this world, but I'm
definitely gonna try.
- Yeah, and hey, I'm like
(applause)
a firm believer, I'm a firm believer.
I'm a church kid, so even if you help
one person it's worth it.
- [Calais] Oh yeah.
- You know, and you're
helping way more than that.
But even if it is just one
you're still a super hero
if you're helping someone.
Tell us about your CRC Foundation.
- I started it with my family.
A bunch of my brothers and sisters are,
I have seven siblings, and--
- Wow!
Your mom.
Okay. (laughs)
- She's an incredible woman.
- She is a mighty one!
- But we just wanted to do something
for my dad's legacy, and I got to the NFL
and I saw this platform,
and just this ability to be
able to help so many people,
and so we tried to just
find different ways
to help so many kids, and it really
comes down to just, you
know, spending time.
You know I try to, I'm a
church-going person as well
and I try to say that I'm gonna
give 10% of my time to charity,
and to giving back and
making a difference.
And that's all I can do sometimes.
- Yeah, like tithing, yeah, yeah.
- But it is definitely
something that is special to me.
- The best kind of human,
I think, is consistent.
And that's because the
worst kind, I feel like,
is an inconsistent human,
and I think especially
when you help with kids,
like that's the coolest
thing that you're still
constantly kind of
appearing in their lives,
and not going away so thank you for that.
- My pleasure.
- But what are some things
the CRC Foundation does?
Like how do they help?
- Well, we do a lot, but I think
the things that we really
try to focus on is really,
so, when I was younger,
I was in seventh grade,
and I really didn't enjoy reading.
You know, I read 'cause I had to.
And then I had a teacher challenge me,
and like put a book in front of me.
And that really connected with me, and
then I started reading all the time.
I loved reading from that point on.
So now my biggest goal is to really just
get kids involved in reading,
so I created reading programs,
and I'm just trying to
find ways to make reading
more fun for a lot of the kids.
- Yeah, but last season you created the
Season of Giving what is that about?
- Because of this great job I have,
you've got this big platform.
And there are a lot of
charities that I like,
and I wanted to really
help bring exposure,
some awareness to some charities
that really meant a lot to me.
So I created this Season of Giving.
I'm gonna take $100,000 I want to give
so I went in and looked
at my stats for the last
five years and I broke it
down, and I was like okay,
I'm gonna give 5,000 for a sack,
give 10,000 for like a
touchdown or a big turnover.
- Yeah. That's cool.
- Give 1,000 for just winning the game.
So my goal was to give
20,000 to each charity,
and so I did four different charities.
And then when I was in
Denver I broke it down to
four charities from where I'm from
'cause we were playing in
Denver, which was incredible.
- What?
- We won the game and it
was awesome it was a lot of fun.
- Are you ever like, mmm,
if I do that I'll owe,
mmm I'll leave that one there.
(laughing)
- It's amazing though and it makes it
fun too for like the kids watching,
and the families watching.
Like "Oh my God. That's
two grand right there!"
That's pretty cool.
- And the people want to
give a lot along with me too.
So it was like they
could donate too through
the website we had.
- Ah, what a clever idea!
- It was pretty cool.
- Yeah, all right!
So Calais, your foundation also gives out
scholarships I hear?
- This is true.
- This is awesome 'cause
like that's a huge thing.
Rackin' up all that debt
for college students.
That's really cool.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that
I want to inspire people and help people
like that to actually have potential to do
something with their lives,
and it really started out helping people
come from similar backgrounds as me.
- Yeah.
- Big families, financially
stressful and need help.
And so I've given away a
few scholarships in my day.
- That's amazing 'cause a lot of people
give up on that dream because they can't,
like I couldn't have gone if I hadn't been
able to get financial
help 'cause of singing.
Like that's how I had to
get scholarships and stuff.
- If it wasn't for sports
I wouldn't have been
able to go to college
either without scholarships.
You know?
- Yeah, you think you
could've gotten a sports
scholarship there Dave?
What uh?
- Kelly, I'm not on trial here.
(laughing)
- Listen, I'm still baffled
you got a singing scholarship.
Is that something?
- Well I got, yeah, oh yeah!
I sang opera and stuff
so I got, I could've,
but then I ended up trying out for Idol.
So it worked.
My mom was not happy.
- Ah. You flushed it all down the toilet.
- Well my mom was not
happy that I was like
so instead of taking advantage of this
scholarship I worked hard to earn,
I'm gonna move to L.A.
and live on a mattress
and try and be a singer!
(laughing)
- Oh. And then what happened?
- Well I,
(laughing)
no, actually what's
funny is I worked here,
'cause such a hard time,
my place burned down,
lived in my car for two days,
drove back home, auditioned for Idol.
So yeah, You know what?
Maybe go to college.
(applauding)
- Good job.
- All right well Calais
doesn't know this, but
we have a woman here
who says he completely
changed the course of her life forever.
Seven years ago she'd
almost given up on her
dreams to go to college.
She just didn't think she could afford it.
That is until she met Calais.
Now not only is she a college graduate,
she's researching ways to cure HIV.
Please welcome Deanna, ya'll!
(cheering)
(uplifting music)
- Gosh, I love your whole look!
You are so cute!
Oh my gosh!
(uplifting music)
- Have a seat, have a seat!
She's like move over, that's my seat.
So Deanna what stopped you from going to
college right after high school?
- The biggest thing that
stopped me was financials.
I was a middle child, I
was pretty good at school,
I loved studying the
sciences, but most people
around me either they tried to pursue
higher education and
didn't finish, or they
didn't have the money in the first place.
So they wouldn't even go.
So it kind of was out of
my range of possibility.
- Yeah, and that happens
to a lot of people.
College is expensive.
- Yes.
- But how did you land this scholarship?
How did that happen?
- Fate.
Stars aligned. (laughs)
- They're in your favor
- Yeah, a mutual friend of
my family introduced me to
his sister Keann and the moment
I met her we like clicked.
And we did a lot of things
like we went to Costco
this one time and bought a bunch of food,
handed it out to the homeless downtown.
- [Kelly] That's cool!
- We had a bunch of charity events that
we did all around Arizona.
So one day her and
Calais invite me to this
fancy schmancy restaurant, and I swear,
I walked in and I was the only kid.
All these people had 401k's and families,
and I'm sitting there
sipping on apple juice
in the corner trying not to be noticed.
And I hear my name, they're like,
"Deanna, come to the stage."
And I was just like;
"Okay, what's going on?"
And they go, "You got a
scholarship to go to college."
And Calais goes, "Congratulations!"
And I'm like: "What just happened?"
- [Kelly] You had no idea.
- [Deanna] Oh no it might be because
I was just a child, but--
- [Kelly] Best surprise
ever. That's amazing!
- It was amazing.
- 'Cause I mean,
I feel like so many people
just need that opportunity
and so many people are suppressed,
because you can't fly, you
know, if somebody's cutting
off your wings you don't
even have the opportunity.
So that's amazing!
- Absolutely.
- So how did the scholarship and college,
how do you feel like
that changed your life?
- For me, college was the foundation
for who I am as a person.
So I ended up going to
High Point University in
High Point, North Carolina,
and I majored in biology.
And the greatest thing
was not worrying about
financials I was able to study harder,
I was able to do outreach,
volunteering, music.
Just expanding all of my horizons because
I had less things to worry about.
So all those research
experiences eventually
led me to where I am now, which I'm a
Senior Research Support Specialist at
SUNY Upstate Medical University.
(Cheering)
- Amazing!
And I love this story because look at
what we would have missed out on.
Like she just couldn't
get in the building,
you know what I'm saying?
And like, we would have missed out.
And you might end up
being one of the people
to like really change the trajectory of
people's health and lives and that's like,
it just drives me insane
how expensive college is but whatever.
Different show, different time, whatever.
(laughing)
Deanna, you have something you
wanted to say to Calais right?
- [Deanna] Yes.
- Go ahead.
- Thank you.
I know that there's a
lot of ways that you can
say that, but honestly without you, and
the generosity of your family,
and, you know, the Foundation,
I would not have been
able to be who I am
today and the best thing
I hope I can do in the
future is that, you know,
I can open the door that you opened for me
for someone who can't even get
close enough to knock on it.
So, thank you.
(applauding)
- How's that make you feel man?
You're like changing lives!
- Incredible.
I've got chills down my back.
Like I mean, when you
give back you just hope
that somebody's like
listening or somebody can
take advantage of it and
like, you just don't know.
You just try to do so
much and then like sitting
here and hearing her speak
like this, this is incredible.
It makes it all worth it.
- You're absolutely right too though.
Plenty of people are given opportunity,
but not everybody takes advantage of it,
and not everybody really runs with it,
and that is a shining
example of your character.
- Thank you.
- And, can I just comment on your hair?
When you turned sideways
I was like: "Okay!"
Your hair is so awesome right now!
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.